my  empathy fatigue is so real do not ask me  to give a [ __ ]  about you when you get sick and you  haven't had the vaccine i  don't  care if you get sick empathy fatigue is  more like  empathy rage  so  empathy is when when you have a feeling  for someone based on a perceived sort of  similarity well i could see myself in  their place right as opposed to sympathy  which is like well i don't really know  how that feels but i feel bad for you  anyway empathy is like i know i see  myself in that situation but she doesn't  she manifestly does not so it's the  opposite of empathy libs love to talk  about empathy now even though they  apparently don't know what it means but  a much better guide to your interactions  with your neighbors is charity it's  charity it's caring for someone it is  willing the good of the other person  going out of your way whether or not you  see yourself in that person